♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL CONVENTION
KICKS OFF TONIGHT AND WE WILL
HAVE THE COVERAGE OF THE
SPEECHES VERY SOON.
IT IS WORTH KNOWING WHERE THE
DEMOCRATS STAND.
WHAT ARE ADVOCATING FOR?
FOR THAT, TAKE A LOOK AT THE
PLATFORM.
THERE’S A LOT IN THERE THAT YOU
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT, INCLUDING
ELIMINATING THE NATION’S PRISONS
PRISONS, TRANSFORMING THE
SUBURBS TO LOW-INCOME HOUSING.
AND THEN THERE IS ABORTION
ACCESS FOR MEN.
ABORTION ACCESS FOR MEN.
NOW, THIS MIGHT FEEL LIKE A BAD
JOKE, BUT THAT’S WHERE JOE BIDEN
COMES IN.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASSURE YOU OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THAT NOTHING
COULD BE MORE SERIOUS PROVIDING
ABORTIONS FOR MEN.
>> OF THE WORLD WATCHES THE
DEBATES.
IT’S NOT A JOKE.
NOT A JOKE.
FACT.
NO, NO, THINK ABOUT IT.
I’M NOT JOKING.
I REALLY MEAN IT.
FOR REAL, YOU THINK I’M JOKING.
I’M NOT JOKING.
YOU HEAR ME?
NOT A JOKE.
>> THAT IS NOT A JOKE.
I REALLY MEAN IT.
NOT A JOKE.
IT’S NOT A JOKE.
>> YOU THINK I’M JOKING.
I’M NOT JOKING.
>> Tucker: WE ALL REPEAT
OURSELVES AS WE GET OLDER.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE, IT’S NOT A
JOKE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, A MAJOR
PARTY, 1 OF 2 IS RUNNING ON THE
PLATFORM THAT CLAIMS MEN CAN GET
PREGNANT.
NOBODY IS SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS.
SARAH IS A WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY, AUTHOR OF THE
UPCOMING BOOK, SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF."
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
SARAH, THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
I OFTEN WONDER AS I WATCH THE
COVERAGE OF THIS CAMPAIGN, BUT
POLITICS MORE BROADLY, WHY DO WE
HEAR SO LITTLE ABOUT THE IDEAS?
ONE PARTY CLAIMS MEN CAN GET
PREGNANT.
THAT’S INSANE.
WHY IS THAT NOT A HEADLINE?
>> EVEN IF YOU TAKE MEN OUT OF
THE EQUATION AND YOU FOCUS ON
THE POINT THAT THEY SUPPORT IT,
THAT ALONE IS DISGRACEFUL AND
SHOULD DISQUALIFY JOE BIDEN FROM
BEING PRESIDENT.
YOU HEAR THEM FALSELY TALK ABOUT
HOW THEY HAVE COMPASSION AND
EMPATHY FOR EVERYONE EXCEPT FOR
THE VERY MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
IN OUR SOCIETY, THE UNBORN
CHILDREN.
THE FACT THAT THEY DON’T STAND
UP FOR THEM AND DO EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO PROTECT THEM I THINK
DISQUALIFIES THEM.
ANY PERSON THAT IS PRO-LIFE
SHOULD HAVE NO ABILITY TO VOTE
FOR JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS
WHO MAKE THIS PART OF THEIR
PARTY PLATFORM AND A PILLAR OF
WHAT THEY STAND FOR.
NOT ONLY WILL THEY NOT PROTECT
CHILDREN IN THE WOMB, THEY ALSO
WON’T PROTECT THEM IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS A PARTY WHO NEVER WAS
SEEN BEFORE IN OUR HISTORY HAVE
WE SEEN A POLITICAL PARTY
DISPARAGE THE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN OF OUR POLICE FORCE AND BE
SO TAKEN BY THE LEFT-WING MOB,
THEY DEFUND THE POLICE WING OF
THEIR PARTY, AND ALLOW
COMMUNITIES TO BE COMPLETELY
OVERTAKEN BY CRIME.
ANY PERSON THAT WANTS TO LIVE IN
A SAFE COMMUNITY AND DOESN’T
WANT TO SEE THIS TYPE OF THING
CONTINUE CAN’T IN THEIR
CONSCIOUS VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN AND
THE DEMOCRATS.
THIS SHOULD SERVE AS A WAKE-UP
CALL TO EVERY COMMUNITY IN
AMERICA THAT HAS BEEN RAVAGED BY
CRIME.
THIS IS NOT A TICKET YOU CAN
TRUST TO MAKE YOU SAFER.
IN FACT, ITS OPPOSITE.
I THINK THE IDEA THAT THEY ARE
FOR COMPASSION AND EMPATHY.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE FROM THE
CORPORATE POSITION, WHICH IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE DISPOSABLE AND
YOU CAN DIVIDE THE COUNTRY.
THE DEMOCRATS ANNOUNCED TODAY
THAT ONE OF THE LOBBYISTS AT
GOOGLE, WHO SHOULD I SAY IN THE
INTEREST OF FAIRNESS, I KNOW
PERSONALLY AND IS A VERY NICE
PERSON.
BUT STILL, ONE OF THE CHIEF
LOBBYIST AT GOOGLE WILL BE ONE
OF THEIR MORE CONVENTION
SPEAKERS.
>> NOT AT ALL.
I THINK WE HAVE SEEN BIG TECH
AGGRESSIVELY START TO CENSOR
CONSERVATIVES.
WHERE ARE ALL OF THE TECH
COMPANIES CENSORING PEOPLE WHO
SPREAD FOR TWO YEARS THE RUSSIAN
WHICH HUNT THAT TRIED TO DESTROY
OUR COUNTRY AND TAKE DOWN A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT?
WHERE WERE THEY?
NONEXISTENT.
THE ONLY START TO SILENCE PEOPLE
WHEN THEY HAVE OPINIONS THEY
DON’T AGREE WITH.
IT IS A VERY DANGEROUS ROAD AND
I THINK YOU CAN SEE HOW THEY
WORK HAND-IN-HAND CONSTANTLY.
I THINK THE CONVENTION IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE.
AND A SAD ONE AT THAT.